bhd ich [ __ ] in schnee eine [ __ ] wenn
ich zb geht es mir nicht mehr
es s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video und heute bin ich
zusammen mit mama und ich finde da meine
facebook auch angeschmissen wir werden
hier doubleface kann machen genau dich
und ich hoffe mal du kriegst das
synchronisiert weil wir es irgendwie
nicht großartig vorher besprochen
auf jeden fall gibt es heute challenge
wie seht ihr aus wie sagen wir spielen
heute in challenge ist nur eine
infizierte kiste ich weiß es wieder
nicht wollte ich bin ja schon genug
leute die challenge ist die rap gehört
im hintergrund vielleicht schon beat der
läuft live und dass ihr solltet jedes
mal bevor wir einen gegner töten dürfen
wir dürfen dürfen die ganze verletzten
aber wir dürfen sie erst töten wenn wir
eine line aus ihrem namen gebaut haben
also heute ist die rap challenge strand
und ja ich mein favourit rapper und
bruder macht dabei war super ich komm
ich habe auch eine entfernen lassen
probieren bleibt das reichen der bereits
oder nachher machen wird schon klappen
niemals reicht es doch ich bin da ich
hätte selber rechts und geht rechts und
links rum okay aber erstmal juni wird
das geklappt dass wir los kempten dass
das wir los schnitzeln können genau der
bietet im hintergrund ist um darüber zu
retten werden wir auch gegenseitig
synchronisiert in ordnung die beste
das heißt wir hören genau das gleiche
max sollte jetzt ungefähr das gleiche
horn wie ich ja und wir machen ja die
lines über die namen sonne
wir machen die ganze über die namen aber
die müssen die müssen zumindest lustig
oder witzig sein also wir die leute
wirklich sprechen ein
die namen der spender löschen
max ist natürlich da drin im westen
immer wieder sowie der hand skill ich
für meinen teil bin jetzt nicht so der
oberst quitter ich weiß nicht ich kann
immer nur freestyle wenn ich besoffen
bin doch ich wollte ich jetzt mal zu
ehrlich sagen leute es wird das wird ja
wohl noch erlaubt sein
es kommt einfach kein die mitte tag
fahren
darf man so ehrlich sagen mein marktwert
von der der marke tomtom nicht es kommt
niemand dass ich dort sie kommen nicht
da hast du irgendwas also hast du was
das man irgendwann das uns zurückbauen
wenn ihr nichts machen wenn sie nicht
oder wir bauen uns hier fordern geht
schon gut gibt kann ich nur lachen oder
etwa der könnte meinen rücken denkt denn
ab jack den rücken
ich nehme ein paar blöcke mit ihr okay
ich habe klar drittel hat ist sowieso
eine pause von bizet keller
spezialmaterial okay man ich will noch
eine sache veröffentlichen leute
irgendwann muss dieser part
veröffentlich werden es einfach zu geil
wir haben in köln mit lucia und lucia
gaal in seinem hotelzimmer duschen und
kamera das duschen wir waren die ganze
zeit schon wieso pläne gemacht
ja und luca rat wollte die ganze zeit
über einen plan machen weiter und gehört
werden und wir haben wir die ganze zeit
nur scheiße gelabert und kam luca schon
richtig angepisst in den raum und max
und justin hätte garten hatten garten
bieten
und dann ging der beetle
justine an so sagt es so wir machen den
block blut kommt rein
sieht aus wie ein schwein war das auto
perfekt gepasst leute und halle weg
gesetzt und luca war richtig angepisst
weile wieder keiner zugehört hat die tür
zu gefährlich rausgerannt ich würde es
unbedingt veröffentlichen
hey okay ich mach link ist eine echte
und tomasz x17 okay okay was will ich
angreifen
da muss eben extrem u7 du glaubst du
bist auf der wolke sieben nein ich
gelogen ich sei der echte ich weck dich
ich kann nicht ich habe keine blöcke
viel spaß allein ja was runter sagt los
lass dich nicht fit
okay was kurz die kräften angeln ja
kommt wenn appelle hat es schon was ich
gespielt hat über den 1
und der erzählt total und ein
unternehmen ich lebe ich lebe ich lebe
ich bin unter ihnen ab 1
er warte ich glaube da hinterher ich
glaubte hinterher konnte ihr kommen wir
nach dem schlag einmal runter hier
eingesperrt
du hast jetzt pech so knecht wenn ihr
wollt ihr itunes version
ja ich eine eigenkreation dann lass mein
leben und ich bin mutter gefallen was
als ob was gemacht ich hab einfach hätte
der vorschlag von max war dass wir die
leute schon mal ab aber hinten werden
wir hier noch nie eingreifen können
damit ihr seinen direkten können aber
schon allein über sie gebildet haben man
hat ja schon in die mitte wie derjenige
heißt er wird es heißen kiste in der
mitte ist ich wünsche dass ich nicht
mitfahren kläger 23 war ich oder du für
pfleger 23 den kollegen holen
falls aber auch das nichts zu merken
kläger 23 denn 23
weil ich so bin ich lieber weg vorbei es
war so klar was machst du auch da hatte
ich konnte nichts dafür
ja deswegen soll es auch nicht so
hingehen alter gar nicht witzig
natürlich will eine mitte ist genau das
habe ich gerade eben gesagt player
zwischen einleger und dich an reinheit
abeba daun
du kannst ja auch für mich bist du
kannst dir quasi ans bitten für mich wie
ich könnte die abhalten über den pinguin
sechste ich will die linke ziehen war
super die linke kommt von lingua es
kommt arminen arminia hey wohin
vertreibt familie spanier trotzdem kein
überflieger
super zerstört von sms nice so ist gut
der karte ist und ich mache davon ist
feiert leuten an jedem kids mit max
einfach eine kane einmalig unterstrich
er hat einmalig unter sich sein
teampartner des unter sich sie sehen
unter sich er ist die unterschicht die
unterschicht von deutschland die kleine
halle groupies bei deinen konzerten auf
den mittelstand so sprießt verleugnen es
nicht ich verleugne es nicht ich zog ein
gedicht
mit seinem rush hd und das kann reiner
gehen die geschwind wollte ich heute
noch in dein kind dich mal hinter blick
nach hinten denn der svp hd nun ich
deshalb deutlich lieber hingehen und ihn
mit einem schwert versehen ich will
gehen hey und ich hab das jobben drauf
du bist super auf das auf was ich habe
mir schon welche aktion war mal i make
music der damm der atem
ich will dich fetzen ich fahre mit dem
auto auf der a 7
es hätte spaß spaß nicht geben hier oder
ihre frischen hd du bist weißt wie
schnee wenn ich dich sehe und ich sagte
uli h den schnee eine [ __ ] wenig cc
geht es mir nicht mehr energie ist es
schon etwas weniger betrieben wird ist
ein super biete ich steppen die seife in
der a 7
es hört mich steffin die cypher derart
thema weiß nicht was ist denn seit es
stinkt bitte hier
ich rieche ja der asien durch in deinem
alter ein hartes ist ein anno tobak was
ich will einen spitzen
trinken okay okay was bist du für in rod
drag ich bin so gut ich mache mlg kopf
web mannschaft dann noch denken die
erste machen ist eigentlich wollte ich
ja es ist eigentlich von vorteil kann ja
auch einige gemacht hatte hey ich habs
mal anders ich trinke morgen und
hennessy die hände sind sie denn ich
habe einen scharfen bedeutet schafft
schwannecke oder acht schafft schafft
bedeutet was ist das für eine gestalt
haye macht auch e mail gateway aber ich
lasse mir die einzelnen leute egal jetzt
wahrscheinlich vertraglichen sterbe aber
global global als ob mir das so viel so
dumm
ich hatte ein halbes herz ich halte eine
hochwertige gewinner ich habe meine
gegeben hat und halbes jahr wirtschaft
ist wirklich beeilen denn ich habe mich
super cola klarheit in unser haye den
start nach mass effect im knast
ja okay das war's mit späterer von uns
und von mark wie sonst wie jack max
burger beschreibung